digital has forced us to watch
commercials where commercials have a
countdown and so my question to the
advertising industry is why don't you
make a great product so we actually want
to enjoy it one of the most beloved TV
commercials of all time is the Mean Joe
Greene commercial from Coca-Cola
and one of the other ones is I'd Like to
Teach the World to Sing neither one of
those commercials sold one bottle of
coke on the other hand TV commercials
that are run on the Super Bowl they can
find out how many people ran out during
halftime to the convenience store and
bought that brand and they have
discovered that it is obnoxious annoying
commercials that human beings actually
take action on and then the last part is
people who read Vogue magazine would pay
extra for the issue with ads in it so we
say we hate the ads but we still buy the
things that are in the ads that's just
the way human beings click